so the the biggest open question in in
terms of hyperbolic cones is welcome all
item Baalak cones all iPhone
barleycorn's spectrum the meaning that
they correspond to hyperbolic polynomial
of that form so that there exist
matrices of a certain size such that the
sum so this is from 1 to N and these
matrices can be of any size such that
that cone can be represented as the
hyperbolic cone of such a polynomial so
that's known as the so this is the
generalized tax congestion and it's
it's all generalized because the the
likes congestion was the keys in which
and is equal to three and that's that
was that's solved
so that's due to Hilton and Vinnie curve
and
seven and then also a halo and hamana
the the case in which D is equal to two
so the case in which the polynomials
quadratics is also solved and so that's
due to Nestle and Tom and thus a few
other cases which are known so for
example in the case of the elementary
symmetric functions as a result of
London
[Music]
and so the the question is whether all I
hyperbolic cones can be represented in
that way there is also a so so it's not
clear whether hyperbolic optimization
goes beyond goes beyond that that
setting which but still it's it's an
interesting it's in terms of efficiency
it's it's actually quite interesting
because there could be there is the
question of the representation so I
haven't of the dimension so I haven't
discussed arguments but one thing that
that's nice about hyperbolic
optimization and maybe I should have
said that only maybe I'll change maybe
I'll give one or two easy exercises now
and then I'll I get more time at the end
so so so as an easy as an easy exercise
okay let let me give you an easy
exercise an easy exercise is to show
that if you look at the elementary
symmetric function Sigma n minus 1 so
that's effects so you're taking the
product of all the monomials involving
and minus one of the N variables that
that's that that's indeed spectrally Jo
and I knew how to do that
so we are looking at
so while looking at Sigma n minus 1 of X
is the the sum of I 1 to N of the
product J I of XJ and
[Music]
and so I want to I want to represent the
corresponding convex cone has as a as a
spectrum spectral engine cone so in that
so far I haven't given you many
techniques the only thing I have given
you is the fact that if you take a
[Music]
spanning tree polynomial of a graph or
more generally I take you if I give you
a regular Metroid I look at the basis of
that regular Metroid that it has a so
the guess would be that if I take the
spanning tree polynomial of a cycle
indeed that's that correspond to it so
spanning tree so this is
so now you could you could try so if you
want to prove this result of London one
you could try you might say well maybe
maybe you could show that it's directly
the so spanning three polynomial of a
graph or maybe you could you could show
that if you look at so if I look at for
example in my eye I could say I could
hope that this is the this is the
polynomial corresponding to a regular
Metroid but inferentially that's not
true so so this corresponds it's
corresponds to the Metroid which is a
uniform Metroid on element and elements
and you take every subset of size I but
even the you to phone is actually not
regular
and this is easy to see in fact you to
foam is so one thing so it's it's
actually not even binary and to be
regularly you have to be representable
over every field so so that's the two
element by binary I mean that we
presentable move on the two element
field and so and you know I mean but you
can view directly that YouTube phone is
not regular because if there was a
totally unimodular matrix that
corresponds to it you could assume that
the form of two columns so you have to
have four columns and so when you have a
representation of a Metroid over on some
field you can always assume that you
have an identity matrix you can
eliminate some rows and you can assume
that you have in an identity matrix and
so it's just the rest that you have to
but you you have to make sure that every
two columns would be independent and so
from this column in that column to be
independent this has to be nonzero from
this column in that column to be
independent this no it's just the
opposite
this one has to be nonzero and this one
has to be nonzero these two and
similarly him and them now to be totally
unimodal on you would need this to be
one or minus one each so this is plus
minus 1 plus minus 1 plus minus 1 plus
minus 1 but these two columns should be
independent so one cannot be the - the
other one and you can choose by basic
operations you can choose the sign so
you could assume that this is 1 + 1 for
example and this is 1 and minus 1 but
that's not totally in mode alone because
the determinant of this is 2 so you to
form is not it's not regular on to say
mark
and shows you that it's not binary and
so you you can't use that cause she been
a formula to get to get this so you need
to you need to walk more phone to get a
result like this now again this is
what's one key fact him is that you
might say but in my timid you said so so
one thing that you should realize is the
following is that what an operation that
maintain Aipom velocity so if I have two
polynomials P and Q that on a hyperbolic
in Direction e then if I take if I take
P x times Q X it's also going to be
hyperbolic in Direction e but but what
happens is that what is the cone
corresponding to this so the cone
corresponding to P the cone
corresponding to P X Q X it's going so
one way to do to look at it is that it's
going to be the component that contains
e when I remove the zeros of this so
that's going to be the cone
corresponding to P intersect it with a
cone corresponding to Q so in particular
if if let's say if so if K plus P X
contains let's say is containing Q plus
Q X that means that this
it's just K plus of P X so that means
that I have another hyperbolic
polynomial that represents the same the
same the same cone so what happens is
that when I give you the cone I don't
necessarily give you the polynomial that
corresponds to it so there might be so
this is one polynomial but you might be
able to multiply it by another
hyperbolic polynomial whose contents the
corner of elementary functions
allometric elementary symmetric
functions and and get a spectral
regional representation of it so so
that's that's something that's that's
important to to realize the related
question this is going to be negative
right that not every cup of all
polynomial can be written in this form
yes that's yeah yeah right exactly so by
so it's really from the cones not for
the polynomials yeah exactly
that's a good it's a good point to
emphasize yes yeah that's a result of
yet whose cone is the spectral form yes
for example zisman
so the elementary symmetric function so
you you you asked for exactly so this
one this one for I not equal to n minus
one and not one cannot be represented I
mean but but it is it is spectra the
corresponding cone is not being
represented is a stronger condition than
being determinantal rate by so so you
cannot write you cannot write this as
that for I not equal to the extreme
cases let me because I realized I
haven't said much about why so yeah can
be written as like the cone can be
written but when you blow up the number
of variables by square alright so the
the one thing that I'm not discussing is
that so
so by a spectrum I mean the cone
corresponding to this there are also
shadows of these spectra region and so
so the result of Pablo Parillo and and
Sun Johnson is about shadows of such
things so so this because this result of
Payton Brandon the the size the the size
of these matrices something like end to
the eye on something right
and to the eye while wildest the so what
Perillo and sanderson show is that you
can get them as a shadow of just
quadratic size no no no they show that
the they show that the elementary
symmetric functions can be that the the
hyperbolic Cohen corresponding to it can
be viewed as a shadow of a spectrum
corresponding to matrices of size
quadratic is a projection
it's um thanks for smooth right smooth
yeah
[Applause]
gradient nonzero and
right that's my question was that bring
up my question about how do we know
about lower so like I know for this day
the square below so da da no so
essentially so in in terms of
projections then there are some some
reasons but in terms of if you just look
at the size of these it's actually to
the best of my knowledge that's
completely open what what the size might
be no it's not oh no it's not known to
be always polynomial I mean so for
example I can i can tell you my Fein one
of my favorite question is the following
so that I told you that all polygons all
polygons cone cones are hyperbolic
because the so if if I have P of X which
is just the product of a bunch of linear
functions
that's hyperbolic and but I'd love to
but there could be so this could be an
exponential number of terms so for
example if I look at let's say if I look
at let's say let me take a graph and let
me look at the matchings all the
matchings in the graph in graph G and
let me look at let me look at the
polynomial that corresponds to the the
conic hull of the matchings in the in
the graph so what I'm going to look at
is let's say the product for example
let's say overall sets s of on C's as
odd maybe X naught x as minus 1 over 2
minus the sum over the edges within s of
X C so if I if I take this exponential
number of Millennium functions so these
are functions in the so in terms of the
edges of the graph plus one one variable
to organize it so that corresponds to
the two two if you'd like if you look at
the matching polytope you have one facet
for each facet of the matching polytope
I have one such inequality now that's
hyperbolic but it's known that if you
try to view that as the projection of a
polygem cone you still need an X
a number of inequalities that's a result
of of Thomas was was but you might be
able to represent it as a example as you
know projection or of a spectrum cone so
and and why do why do I care about this
it's partly because and I guess I
so I'm a bit confused by the schedule
because I've been a bit should I should
I at some point stop a bit and at some
point I should stop from 15 minutes okay
good but let me let me say one thing
that I find so you might say okay fine
you defined hyperbolic optimization as
minimizing minimizing CX subject to
let's say X is equal to B and X is in
this hyperbolic code but why is that I
mean for many cases is that easy to I
mean it has some easy special cases like
linear programming semi definite
programming but it's actually it's it's
very it's often easy to optimize over
this and it's simply because one can
show that if I look at minus the log of
P of X so what is so I have K plus plus
and I know that k plus plus is the
component in so of n minus P of X is
equal to 0 that contains the pollak
Direction e and so minus log of P of X
is a function that actually goes to
infinity as you approach the boundary
but that's a that's a bombing function
so from people doing convex optimization
they like to have a bunion function
that's a function that's smooth and well
behaved and that goes to that goes to
infinity as you go to towards the
boundary of the set and that has some
additional nice property and so one one
interesting property of this is that the
fact that P of X is a polynomial means
that if you look at the derivatives of
that barrier function along any line the
you can relate
films derivative to the second
derivative and its own derivative down
reasonably well behaved and so in
particular one can show and I think this
was probably from stop zoom by guru can
show that minus log of P of X is a self
component volume function and self
concurrent functions come with the Pamir
ins which gives you the complexity but
the parameter in this case is the degree
of the polynomial which permit on D with
permit on D for any for any hyperbolic
polynomial D polynomial so this means
that so this notion of self from
continent function I can define it if
you'd like but so this was a notion that
was introduced by mr. Hoff enemy have
ski and it was it was introduced to show
that to see what you need what kind of
properties you need from the bearing of
function so that Newton's method
converges quickly and and indeed once it
is self confident you can use Newton's
method and it will converge quickly to
an approximately optimum solution to
this optimization problem so so what it
means is that if you have a hyperbolic
optimization problems from which you can
evaluate P effects
then you can actually efficiently so if
you can evaluate it so if you can if one
can evaluate the effects efficiently one
can optimize up to 2 Epsilon efficiently
overseas ax is equal to B X and so I
mean infinitely when you have let's say
a function 90s that has an exponential
number of terms it's not clear how to
evaluate that so so so you need to you
need to find hyperbolic polynomials that
you can evaluate not to my knowledge if
we could evaluate that yes exactly I
mean I said I said that you need to
evaluate P effects there is also and
maybe I'll get I'll get I've lost this
time of the schedule maybe I'll get back
to it
but so supposedly for Newton's method
you have to evaluate not just the volume
function but you have to be able to come
to evaluate also gradient and Hessians
the fact that so when I can for example
showed that the fact that you can
evaluate the function in that polynomial
means that by
interpolation you can easily evaluate
the gradient and the and iation
at least at least if it is exact it's
easy if it is not an exact I don't quite
exactly you can kind of do it if you
know how far the roots 0 yeah so but
yeah I don't know if yeah I don't know
if the yeah I I don't know yeah yeah
that um yeah I I don't know if it is
good enough I yeah I presume it's not
good enough
so should I pose for 15 minutes and then
start again yeah ok
[Applause]